e aí
as pessoas essas pessoas essas pessoas
mas o lado da essas pessoas nas aulas
[Música]
tão preocupado assim não
a irmã morreu a
é muito obrigado amor
olá é um prazer a gente tá aqui abrindo
esse evento nós somos o berço nós somos
aqui de niterói meu nome é pedro braga
esses são os meus filhos henrique
chaffin e o joão pedro braga e é assim
muito legal a gente está aqui nós três
juntos fazendo música para vocês eu
costumo dizer que a gente cresceu junto
musicalmente um ambiente de muito ritmo
muita melodia muita harmonia harmonia
musical mas também familiar a gente tá
tocando junto algum tempo e
desenvolvemos isso sim uma antiguidade
uma afinidade musical muito bonita e ao
longo desses anos a gente abre entendeu
que a gente tinha aqui formar esse trio
de violões e começamos então a compor
música
a ver alguns arranjos como diz que a
gente acabou de tocar que é uma
homenagem a nossa música popular
brasileira né do caetano veloso e
gilberto gil inclusive foi feito
especialmente para essa ocasião aqui
para gente fazer essa abertura
i e ii
e agora dando prosseguimento a gente vai
tocar também um metro aí de uma banda
que a gente gosta muito que é os beatles
muito obrigado
e aí
é muito obrigado a gente agora vai tocar
a nossa última música é uma homenagem
também à uma banda que me influenciou
muito os novos baianos e eu acho que
acredito que influenciou eles por tabela
também então é
e chama-se um bilhete para dividir eu
gostaria de dizer também que eu estou
muito feliz de estar com vocês aqui
então eu acho que
é a nossa música vem de berço na verdade
literalmente né muito obrigada
e aí